My parents raised me or my stepmom was the daughter of the American revolution.
And my father, who is an immigrant from Alexandria Egypt.
And I'd spent a lot of my summers in Alexandria with my grandmother who never
got to go to school despite being one of the wisest people I've ever met.
And she made a habit of reminding me that there was nothing special about me.
There was only something special about my opportunities.
She pointed out one cousin and be like, you know,
that was smarter than you point out to another one. She said that one's is,
is better looking than you pointed out to a third one that was taller than you.
And her point was that you owe your opportunities a responsibility.
And I think that that's one of the best things about being the child of
immigrants is that I know exactly what opportunities I had because I saw the
contrapositive. And so the crazy thing is that on those trips to Egypt,
I would travel about 15 hours and travel about 10 years
difference in life expectancy.
And I could travel the same tenure life expectancy gap in 25 minutes.
If I were to leave my suburban Detroit home and drive to any neighborhood in
Detroit, and that always framed why I became a doctor in the first place,
the work that I wanted to do.
One of the things in your story that impressed me the most.
And there are a lot of very impressive things,
but so you're married in New York,
you're a professor at Columbia,
and then you wound up dropping everything to go back to Detroit,
to run the department of health.
That at that point was really poorly resourced. You know,
you had to like go and, uh,
you had to be a apart from your wife.
That to me is in many ways the biggest Testament to
your spirit of service because you and I
know a lot of people who came through the meritocracy and had like the
opportunity to teach it at Ivy league universities and whatnot,
and not many of them do what you did.
Well, I, I appreciate you saying that. I, um, you know, for me,
that was just that that's the responsibility I owed the opportunities that I was
given. And so it's easy to get too complex about your,
your personal calculations, right? Should I do this? Should I do that?
But for me that the simple litmus test is what would my Tate, I think, right?
What would she say about what I chose to do and whether or not it was worthy
of the very unique opportunities that I got. And so that's why I did it.
I hope that that focus remains always for me,
that sense of dignifying your opportunity,
because you do something you talk about quite a bit in, in your work, Andrew,
and something I really admired about the clarity of your run is that at the end
of the day, you, your privilege is always creating privilege somewhere.
You're either increasing privilege for people who already have it,
or you're providing a modicum for people who don't and like, that's the choice.
So, you know, you, you work up the meritocracy, you, you get,
you get knighted by all these institutions who put their seal of approval on
you. And the question you have to ask yourself is, well, is what you're doing.
You know, what the was that for exactly? What was the point? Well.
We'll see, here's the thing. If, if I say to someone, Hey, Abdul,
or doctor twice over Abdul,
El-Sayed goes home to Detroit to run the department of health. People say, okay,
that sounds very like important and official,
but I know what the reality is. Just like,
you know what the reality is where you like show up in Detroit,
you have this skeleton crew in the back of the parking office,
like the hospital that used to house,
it is shuttered your first task as like the person trying to increase people's
life expectancy is to deal with a Vagrant dog problem because the freaking dogs
are like roaming the streets of Detroit.
And I spent a lot of time in Detroit and even, I didn't know that one,
I was like, what? Like you had a freaking, uh, you know, it's like,
there's like the official storybook version.
And then there's like the real life version.
And I know what the real life version looked like.
Having spent enough time in that city.
I was working,
I was working probably 110,
120 hour weeks.
I got a little studio in downtown and I'd be in the
office by eight. I'd leave the office by nine or 10.
And I would do that six to seven days a week.
And like the only time that I wasn't there,
I was in New York where I would generally be with Saraj. But like,
if she was a, she was a resident physician. And so she had weekend hours and,
you know,
I would need to get out and just keep working because things kept going.
There were a lot of days where I was like, what are we doing here? Um,
that's just impossible. You're right. Like, you know, you walk in a,
and you've got five city employees,
85 contractors in the back of the building where people go to pay parking
tickets in the poorest city in America. I I'll be honest. I, you know,
I've done a number of things since,
but I don't know that I'll ever be as fulfilled in a job as I
was in those moments, uh, at the health department,
because it was the thrill of doing something unique for people who really,
really needed it.
And rarely is work that unencumbered morally.
Yeah, it'd be so pure. You're literally, it's like, Hey,
I'm just here to try and make your kids life longer and healthier.
Uh, and, and one of the stories I loved in your book is like,
you just sort of show up at people's doorsteps on like Friday afternoons being
like, Hey, like what's going on? Like, what's going wrong in your neighborhood.
One of the things that broke my heart was the fact that you identified that
demolishing buildings in Detroit actually contributed to an increased risk of
lead poisoning for the kids who are near the demolished houses,
because so Detroit peak population, 1.7 million,
right. Current population, approximately 680,000, that's right.
Something along those lines. So the thing is almost two thirds empty.
So you'll look around and the way Detroit's laid out is that it's a fairly large
area. It's not like ILO Manhattan is like super densely populated.
It's like fairly spread out. It's huge. You could fit all.
Of Boston, Manhattan and San Francisco and Detroit and still have room leftover.
Yeah.
Yeah. So it it's kind of spread out and it's almost two thirds empty.
So you have all these buildings that are derelict, uh,
hazardous bladed. So the fact that they were trying to demolish them,
I was for the fact that unfortunately the building materials have had
lead paint on them, such that if you demolish them, lead dust goes up and, uh,
probably ends up increasing health risks for people for blocks around
particularly vulnerable kids. I was like, Oh no,
I got like real sinking feeling. And the fact that you identified that,
you know, to me,
was so profound because I know the people in charge
were very excited about demolishing some buildings.
And that's the thing that the demolitions, weren't the problem. When you,
when you demolish at that scale,
it's almost impossible to hold all of the contractors who are actually doing the
demolishing accountable. And so, you know,
of course they're going to cut corners and they're going to cheat.
And when they do that means that the lead that was, you know,
packed away in the inside of those homes gets out and, you know,
you've got a kid playing outside or a kid opening the window and trying to study
in the room, that's going to get in their lungs. And that has consequences.
And unfortunately, when we analyzed it, that's what we found.
And so it was really frustrating, right? Because you know,
this is a high profile program, a program that has a lot of money going into it,
and nobody wants to hear bad news,
but this sort of gets to the beginning of the conversation that we had, Andrew,
which is in public health.
The hard part about public health is that if you're allowed and you ring the
alarm bells, right. People are like, yeah, this is, this is not a big deal.
Right. It's going to be just fine. And if you're quiet, then bad things happen.
And so you're constantly fighting a losing battle.
And here we are in the middle of a coronavirus pandemic,
that really is the same story, Alex Azar,
for all of the things I disagree with him on, right.
Tried to ring the alarm bells about this pandemic. Well,
before it became a global pandemic and they shouted him down, right. They, they,
they shushed him up and here we are. And so, you know, I know that experience,
right.
I literally got called Cassandra by the higher ups in the office because every
time I'd come in, I'd be like, look, I've got bad news for you.
And let me tell you how this is gonna hurt kids. And they'd be like, Oh, well,
you know,